hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir schauen heute auf die nächste
vielleicht entscheidende Phase der
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive wir schauen
auf den Frontverlauf und auf die ganz
verschiedenen Meldungen die es aktuell
zu diesem Thema gibt zum einen sprechen
wir über den Einsatz der 82
Luftlandebrigade die soll nämlich auch
Challenger zwei Panzer und erstmals
deutsche Marder an der Front einsetzen
darüber hinaus gibt es wohl aber kaum
noch Reserven und wir gucken natürlich
auch noch mal generell auf die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive die schreitet
nämlich im Südosten der Ukraine
schleppend voran unter großen Verlusten
in den harten Kämpfen der letzten Wochen
ist am Mittwoch aber ein wichtiger
Erfolg vermeldet worden orange wurde
befreit das hat die ukrainische Armee
mitgeteilt der kleine Ortner saporisa
ist von den ukrainischen Bodentruppen
eingenommen worden die russischen gegen
Manöver konnten mit den überlegenden
Waffen verhindert werden die vom Besten
bereitgestellt wurden nach tagelangem
Artilleriebeschuss haben also
ukrainische Soldaten ihre Flagge im
strategisch wichtigen Ort an der
Frontlinie
da sehen wir noch mal die Bilder dazu
ja in der Region Donezk ist orosina
einer der Punkte der am weitesten in der
vermieten Verteidigungslinie der Russen
liegt mittlerweile geht unter anderem
von dort auch die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive in Richtung milito-pohl
weiter in das einige Dutzend Kilometer
entfernte robotine hat das ukrainische
Militär diese 82 luftlande Brigade
verlegt von der ich ganz am Anfang
gesprochen habe und deswegen wollen wir
halt gucken was ist das scheinbar
Besondere an dieser Luft Lande Brigade
über die wird gerade viel gesprochen wie
steht es um die gegen Offensive und auch
immer am wichtigsten wie geht es
eigentlich den Ukrainern und
Ukrainerinnen mit dieser Situation und
das alles besprechen wir heute zum einen
mit Militärexperte Gustav Ressel wenn
ihr ZDF heute live öfter schaut dann
kennt ihr den schon und mit meiner
Kollegin und ZDF reporterin Anne Brühe
und wie immer auch mit euch da draußen
vom PC oder vom Smartphone oder vom
Fernseher wenn ihr Fragen an meine Gäste
habt oder einfach eure Meinung zum Thema
mit uns teilen wird dann tut das für
immer gerne einfach hier im Youtube Chat
oder per ma il an die jetzt
eingeblendete Adresse und jetzt schauen
wir aber erstmal mit Militär Experte
Gustav Kresse auf die Lage an der
Südfront und da ist er mir zugeschaltet
hallo Herr Kresse guten Abend
es sprechen ja gerade viele Menschen
über robotine da ist jetzt die 82
Luftlandebrigade und die zählt 2000
Soldaten wie groß könnte der Impact
dieser Brigade jetzt sein also was
zeichnet sie aus
sie zeichnet in erster Linie aus dass
sie eine ältere Brigade ist also sie ist
nicht neu aufgestellt worden nur für die
gegen Offensive und die gibt's schon
seit einiger Zeit die die ukrainischen
landeverbände es sind ja nicht Luft
Lande wie wir uns das im herkömmlichen
sind vorstellen sondern das waren in der
vorkriegsarmee in der ukrainischen
Freiwilligen aus gestattete Elite
Verbände die als schnelle Feuerwehr im
dombas eingesetzt wurden
die bestehen alle aus sehr erfahrenen
Kadern die hatten immer schon schwere
Waffen also ein Panzerbataillon und dann
zwei bis drei
mechanisierte in Vertrieb Bataillone
manchmal auf BMP manchmal auf btsr also
auf
kettenschützenpanzer oder
radschützenpanzer das heißt die kennen
auch die angriffsverfahren die
kampfverfahren Verzögerung Verteidigung
mit mechanisierten Gerät und die wurden
jetzt natürlich mit westlichem Gerät neu
ausgestattet das heißt haben ihre alten
BTS und BMPs gegen Marder getauscht und
alternativ 64 gegen Challenger
und das ist natürlich das was diese
Brigade jetzt natürlich Aufmaß die kann
das mechanisierte Gefecht sie schon sehr
lange eingespielt
sie besteht aus erfahrenen Leuten und
die können natürlich dann das Potenzial
diese Geräte auch voll nutzen
ja also eine ältere erfahrenere Brigade
dann aber auch der Tausch dieser
Gerätschaften jetzt stellen sich viele
die Frage ist das denn jetzt ein
qualitativ besseres Gerät jetzt ja auch
erstmal mit den Marder mit den
mörderpanzern dort vor Ort das ist
natürlich im Vergleich zum sowjetischen
Gerät ein ein besseres Gerät also wenn
man zum Beispiel Vergleich den bmp1 der
quasi das Standard
kettenschützenpanzer in ukrainischen
Armee ist dann hat der bmp1 erst erstens
mal eine sehr schlechte Optik mit der
immer sehr wenig sieht vor allen Dingen
wenn es dunkler wird das zweite hat eine
73 mm klapprohrkanone mit der man sehr
wenig trifft vor allen Dingen wenn Wind
geht weil diese Geschosse diesen Flügel
stabilisiert und fliegen sehr langsam
die werden doch Wind sehr gerne
abgetragen und Land dann neben dem Ziel
man kann also Feuer Unterstützung nur
sehr schlecht und nur sehr kurze Distanz
leisten da war der 2 cm Maschinenkanone
die sehr prä ist er hat gute Optiken er
ist weit robuster gebaut
er hat innen mehr Platz für Mann und
Ausrüstung die
modschützen die drin sitzen die sitzen
nicht auf den Treibstoffleitungen die
quer durchs Fahrzeug verlegt sind und
die Tür durch diese raus müssen bei
Marder in die es nicht wie beim BMP ein
Treibstoff Tank verbaut der die
unangenehme Eigenschaft hat in vielen
Gefechten Feuer zu fangen und man dann
nicht sozusagen durch die brennende Luke
aussteigen muss all das sind natürlich
Vorteile die normal dagegen über den BMP
hat aber muss auch sagen dass Material
allein ist es nicht also vorher bei dem
Sektor eingesetzt die 47 mechanisierte
Brigade lieber ausgestatte mit Leopard 2
und
Bradley Schützenpanzer seinem
amerikanische Schützenpanzer Modell und
tatsächlich dabei schwerer das ist eine
neu aufgestellte Brigade die das
Personal dort kommt aus der leichten
infan wieder so hat vorher zu Fuß
gekämpft und sozusagen muss ich jetzt an
das mechanisierte Gefecht dann an Ketten
unter den Füßen haben gewöhnen wo alle
gefechtsabläufe viel schneller
vonstatten gehen als wenn ich rein zu
Fuß angreife und der Bradley ist
mit Mara mindestens gleichwertig wenn
ich sogar der bessere Schützenpanzer
Weiler
vor allen Dingen was seine
wärmebildoptik angeht besser
ausgestattet ist auch eine Panzer für
Lenkwaffe größere Reichweite mit verbaut
oder etc aber es hängt eben auch viel
davon ab wie ich sie Einsätze wie
erfahren die Leute sind die drin und
drauf sitzen auf diesem Gerät um es
synchronisiert den verbunden mit
artillerin verbunden mit Kampfbahn
seinen verbunden mit pionierkräften im
verbunden mit Flieger Abwehrkräften dann
eben zum Einsatz bringen
also ziemlich viele verschiedene Dinge
auf die es da ankommt um über die
verschiedenen Qualitäten zu sprechen die
soll ja jetzt an der Front bei robotine
eingesetzt werden was könnte sie dort
bringen bzw was sind denn die
Herausforderungen genau an diesem
Frontabschnitt aktuell
dieser Frontabschnitt ist eigentlich
einer der schwierigsten Frontabschnitte
weil dort die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen besonders tief
sind dass ziel dieser offensive oder
dieses Keils die hier relativ nah an
saporisa nach Süden geht ist die Stadt
dogmark das ist ein wichtiger
eisenbahnhof Verkehrsknotenpunkt und
hier sozusagen die die Logistik in der
Russen zu zerschneiden und die
Möglichkeit der Russen von Ost nach West
Truppen zu verlegen durch die Einnahme
dieser Stadt die so sehr schwer
verteidigt da liegen sehr viele leider
sehr viele Minen in der Gegend rum hier
sind die sind drei durchgehend
ausgebaute russische
Verteidigungslinien ähm die ist
Entschuldigung dass der gerade einmal
die könnt ihr da draußen übrigens
erkennen an den roten Punkten bzw Linien
die sich da gerade durch die Karte
ziehen Entschuldigung genau und Robin
ist stand sozusagen am Ende der ersten
also mit mit die erste dieser
Verteidigungslinie durchdrungen und kann
jetzt natürlich weiter angreifen aber
selbst wenn jetzt das Ausnutzen des
Durchbruchs gelingt ist eben das Problem
dass relativ bald wieder dann die eben
die zweite Verteidigungslinie und die
Vorposten Stellungen dieser zweiten
Verteidigungslinie auf die Angreifer
warten und ist eben auch sehr gut
ausgebaut das heißt der Erfolg der war
natürlich taktisch da man hat diese
Linie durch stoßen aber das Ausnutzen
dieses Erfolges das ist an diesem
Frontabschnitt enorm schwer
ja und dann schließlich natürlich gleich
noch die Frage an wenn man jetzt diese
Brigade dorthin verlegt hat ist denn
dort in den kommenden Tagen vielleicht
auch mit so einer Art Großangriff zu
rechnen
man kann in diesen schwer ausgebauten
Stellungen und aufgrund der vielen
Minenfeldern dort sehr schwer Masse zum
Einsatz bringen das heißt auch wenn ich
jetzt weitere Brigaden dort hinein
schicke dann stehen diese Kräfte auf dem
Weg hinunter zu ihrem Einsatz in sehr
entlang sehr schmaler Straßen
entlang der die Russen mit Drohnen
schauen wer da fahrt und wo der Fahrt
und jeder truppenkonfertion wird
unmittelbar mit Artillerie angegriffen
das heißt hier mit Wasser weiterzustoßen
und den Durchbruch sozusagen dann in
einem massiven Schlag auszunutzen ist
durchaus schwer und risikohaft hat
wahrscheinlich
schauen die Ukraine jetzt dass sie eben
an die Vorposten Stellungen rangehen der
nächsten Linie und dann schauen wie
die Russen die zum Teil sehr aggressiv
verteidigen die ersten Gegenangriffe
dann vortragen das bietet den Ukrainern
wieder die Gelegenheit russische Kräfte
abzulösen weil diese Minenfelder nicht
nur die ukrainischen Bewegungen verengen
sondern genauso die russischen
Bewegungen die oft nur sehr wenige
Linien haben um Gegenangriffe zu fahren
und dann schaut man sozusagen wie man in
die zweite Linie reinkommt aber ich
glaube nicht dass jetzt sozusagen aus
dieser Stellung heraus der große massive
Angriff erfolgen wird ganz einfach weil
die Entfaltung von starken Kräften in
diesem Frontabschnitt sehr schwierig
wird
ich habe gerade schon mal einen Blick in
den Chat geworfen und was auf jeden Fall
viele User umtreibt ist die russische
Seite und die Reaktion da drauf hier
wird zum Beispiel gefragt mit wie vielen
Waffensystem kann die russische
Gegenseite Antworten hat die russische
Armee überhaupt noch genug Manpower und
Material
auf dem Papier hat sie das allerdings
ich glaube wir kommen im späteren
Verlauf das Sendung noch dazu
gibt es eine russische Offensive und das
Bereitstellen von starken Kräften für
eine weitere russische Offensive im
Nordosten der Ukraine im Raum Kopierens
und diese offensivtätigkeit verschlingt
viele Kräfte auf russischer Seite die
man als Reservekräfte eigentlich
bräuchte um solche Durchbrüche wie wenn
jetzt in der Routine erlebt haben
auszugleichen die russischen Kräfte die
hier den Ukraine gegenüber stehen sind
sehr lang in ihren Stellungen drin
stehen schon sehr lange im Kampf sind
dementsprechend abgenutzt und zeigen
auch schon Ermüdungserscheinungen und
weil eben man auf russische Seite diese
Koblenz Offensive vorträgt hat man keine
Kräfte diese abgenutzten Kräfte
rauszulösen durch frische zu ersetzen
das könnte ein Fehler sein der sich noch
rächen könnte
äh und den ukrainen Lauben könnte ihre
ihre Stellungen weiter auszubauen und
weiter einzudringen in die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen
weil sie es mit nicht frischen Kräften
zu tun haben die
es 82 luftlandebegarde ist ja relativ
frisch sie stand bis jetzt in Reserve
ist also gut erholt ist voll
aufmunsioniert und dementsprechend hat
sie natürlich auch jetzt im Angriff
wieder mehr und neuen Schwung
mehr und nein Schwung im Angriff der
Ukraine jetzt wird ja aber im Kontext
dieser gerade auch der Brigade auch
immer wieder davon berichtet dass das so
ein bisschen die letzte Reserve der
Ukraine gewesen sein wie schätzen Sie
das denn ein
die Ukraine gibt natürlich nicht bekannt
wie viel Brigaden sie genau noch in der
Hinterhand hat aber ein bisschen was ist
da natürlich schon dran wir haben vor
zweieinhalb Wochen eine Rotation gesehen
das neunte Chor das also die
Gegenoffensive angefangen hat es mit
seinen Kräften mit Masse abgelöst worden
durch eben neue Kräfte aus dem aus dem
zehnten ukrainischen Chor dann haben wir
auch gesehen dass eben zum Auffangen
dieser Offensive dieser russischen
Offensive
im im Raum kopiens
auch wieder heeresreserven hinaufverlegt
wurden das heißt viele der Reserven die
eigentlich dafür vorgesehen waren
Durchbrüche auszunutzen und weiter
auszubauen die stehen jetzt schon im
Kampf und wenn sich wenn man mal durch
die stark ausgebauten Stellungen durch
wäre wobei ich da eher ein bisschen
weiter östlicher als jetzt dogmark im
Verdacht hätte dass man schneller käme
dann stellt sich die Frage wenn man mit
wie viel mit wie starken Kräften kann
man dann ins offene Gelände vordrängen
und kann dann durch Manöver sozusagen
die die Offensive beschleunigen da
denn in dieser Anzahl Phase wenn es dann
schneller werden würde wenn man durch
die Stellungen durchdringt dann treibt
man so einen Art Keil in die russischen
in das russische Dispositiv hinein und
dieser Keil hat ja Flanken in zwei
Richtungen nach Osten nach West äh die
man sichern muss und diese Flanken
Sicherung desto tiefer der Keil wird
verschlingt mehr und mehr Kräfte sind
wir da noch in der Lage den tief zu
treiben oder muss die Ukraine hier die
Ziele Offensive neue definieren das ist
ein knifflige Frage ich schätze dass die
Ukraine hier schon
leider sehr weit mit dem Verbrauch ihrer
Reserven ist die Frage ist kann zum
Beispiel diese Kräfte des 9 Chors die
jetzt rausgenommen wurden wenn man die
neu formiert wenn man die einige Zeit
ruhen lassen wenn man dann wieder
trainiert und
diese Verbände ergänzt durch neues
Material und neues Gerät neue Leute ob
man die dann einsetzen wird können oder
nicht das hängt vom Grad ab wie stark
diese Einheiten abgekämpft sind und kann
ich natürlich sehr schwer beurteilen nur
unmittelbar also jetzt in diese
Situation würde ich sehr zweifeln dass
sie zur Verfügung stehen weil natürlich
abgekämpfte Einheiten erstmal ein
bisschen Ruhe brauchen und wieder
aufgefüllt werden müssen und die neu zu
wechselt die Neuzugänge die neuen Leute
die da reinkommen in diese Verbände
brauchen auch wieder ein bisschen Zeit
um sich an ihre Kameraden zu gewöhnen um
ein bisschen
übungs-routine um sozusagen in die in
die Gänge zu kommen als synchron
ronisierter gefechtsverband und all das
braucht Zeit
ja und von diesem Ort ist Gefechts gehen
wir jetzt noch mal ein Stück weiter in
den Osten nämlich nach oregane das ist
das Dorf dass die Ukraine befreit haben
da habt ihr gerade auch am Anfang die
Bilder zu gesehen was bedeutet denn die
Befreiung dieses Ortes für die Ukraine
diese Angelsachse ist eigentlich eine
der operativ vielversprechendsten weil
hier zwar die die stark ausgebaute
Hauptverteidigungslinie der Russen in
der mehr in der Tiefe liegt das heißt
die Ukraine müssen sich da noch eine
eine Zeit lang anschieben aber hier ist
nur die erste Linie vorhanden und die
hinteren Linien sind nicht
fertiggestellt die befinden sich erst im
Aufbau das heißt wenn man hier dann mal
einen Durchbruch durch die erste Linie
erzielt
hat man die Chance dass man dann ins
offene Gelände kommt dass man dann auch
größere Handlungsspielräume hat mit
Kräften diesen Durchbruch auszunutzen
das Problem an dieser Achse ist
natürlich dass der Weg
hinunter zum also offen mehr länger ist
als weiter westlich das heißt man
braucht dann auch natürlich mehr Kräfte
um die Flanken abzusichern und diesen
Teil weiter zu treiben aber hier besteht
das ukrainischer Sicht natürlich die
Hoffnung dass man nicht praktischen
Erfolge zielt russische Kräfte
vernichtet die Russen aus einem Ort
rauswirft sondern dass man noch drei
Ortschaften weiter und dann in der
Aufstellung sitzt und dann den viel
ersehnten und erwarteten großen
Durchbruch schafft um in die
manöverphase dieser
dieser Gegenoffensive zu kommen und
nicht in der abnutzungsphase stecken
bleibt vielleicht noch mal für alle die
nicht immer bei unseren Ukraine
Livestreams dabei sind können sie noch
mal ganz kurz und kompakt erklären was
ist der Unterschied zwischen einem
taktischen und einem operativen Erfolg
taktisch heißt dass man ein Gefecht für
sich entscheidet operativ heißt dass man
eine Kampagne für sich oder entscheidet
also ein Gefecht ist ich will eine
Ortschaft einnehmen ich will einen Fluss
überqueren ich will einen gewissen
russischen Verband schlagen operativ
wäre dass ich für eine Kampagne
verwertbare Resultate erziele das heißt
für diese gegen Offensive die operativen
Ziele sind die russischen
Verkehrsverbindungen auf die Krim zu
durchschneiden das also viel mehr zu
erreichen
das sind das sind die sozusagen die
großen Ziele der gesamten gegen
Offensive nicht nur der einzelnen
Gefechte sondern der gesamten gegen
Offensive wenn ich jetzt eine Ortschaft
einnehme dann habe ich ein Gefecht
gewonnen ich habe eine taktischen Erfolg
erzielt aber operativ verwehrbares
Ergebnis ist erst wenn ich z.B die
russischen Verkehrslinien durchschneidet
die Richtung Krämpfe führen oder wenn
ich das Arschloch mehr erreiche und hier
ist natürlich
immer die Frage was bringt der taktische
Erfolg und wie steht er in Relation zu
meinen operativen Zielen und ist es
eigentlich schon ein operativ
verwehrbares Ergebnis wenn ich
vielleicht das Ergebnis der Offensive
noch nicht ganz erreicht habe aber dem
schon sehr nahe kommen oder wichtige
Grundbedingungen dafür geschaffen haben
und da ist es halt leider so dass die
Offensive dass die Erfolge der Ukraine
in den letzten Tagen und Wochen alles
Wichtige taktische Erfolge waren aber
das die das operativ verwehrbare
Ergebnisse nämlich der Durchbruch durch
die Linie und der Übergang in schnelle
Manöver dass der noch aus bleibt
ja und von der Militär Strategie kommen
jetzt noch zu einer weiteren Meldung die
heute neu war nämlich dass die also
Brigade der ukrainischen Nationalgarde
nach Angaben Kiews neu aufgestellt ist
und einem Militäroperation an der
Ostfront durchführt was ist ihre
Einschätzung zu dieser Meldung
angebliche sind im Raum verlegt worden
das heißt auch zum Abfangen der
der
Offensive bzw zur zurückschlagen
russischer Kräfte die in ukrainische
Stellungen eingedrungen sind
diese
Brigade war im Raum bachmut hat sich
dort sehr ausgezeichnet war für viele
der dortigen Erfolge mitverantwortlich
und dürfte aus dem Raum auch Mut mal
abgezogen worden sein um sich zu
regenerieren und ist jetzt im Raum
kopiens das zeigt wie wichtig den
Ukrainern dass das verteidigen gegen
diese
anlaufende russische Offensive im
Nordosten ist man muss da er größere und
wichtige Kräfte hinschicken um die
Russen hier zu stoppen ähm das ist ja
das was sozusagen bei der Bewertung wie
viel Reserven haben die Ukraine noch um
die gegen Offensive im Süden weiter zu
treiben das große Fragezeichen ist man
muss aber auf russischer Seite auch
sagen dass diese Offensive
wahrscheinlich den Russen die Kräfte
wegnimmt im Süden auf ukrainische
Durchbrüche wirklich zu reagieren also
unendlich sind die russischen Kräfte
auch nicht also das sind immer die
Vorstellungen bei uns dass hier die
russische Armee ein nicht enden wollen
des Pool an Leuten ist also so nicht
enden wollen ist das ganze natürlich
auch nicht
ja und über die Lage in kobians über die
sprechen wir gleich noch mal Herr
grassel vielen Dank bis hierhin
so und vorher bewegen wir uns jetzt aber
noch mal hoch in den Nordosten der
Ukraine und zwar in die Stadt radev von
dort aus ist uns jetzt live ZDF
Reporterin und meine Kollegin Anne Brühl
zugeschaltet die vorher in herson war da
seht ihr beide Orte einmal eingezeichnet
und sie sollte mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet sein hallo Anne
hallo
Anne du bist jetzt in Hardy warst aber
vorher in herson was hast du dort vor
Ort erlebt
ja wir konnten Anfang der Woche eine
Soldaten begleiten die ihre getöteten
frontkollegen von der Front abholt die
Leichname den Familien in Odessa
übergibt und sie hat mir erzählt früher
hat sie diese Fahrt ein zweimal die
Woche gemacht jetzt macht sie das
eigentlich jeden Tag und sie hat
meistens nicht nur einen Leichnamen in
ihrem improvisierten Transporter liegen
sondern manchmal eben auch drei und vier
das heißt
vermutlich dass diese Offensive nachher
Sohn eben in vollem Gange ist wenn man
versucht dort ja über den Fluss in die
Pro äh zu stoßen mit immer wieder
kleineren vorstoßen und wir haben auch
in Odessa gedreht auf einem normalen
Friedhof da hat das Flaggen mehr der
ukrainischen Flaggen gar nicht mehr
aufgehört über jedem Grab wird ja eine
solche Flagge über jedem Soldaten Grab
und wir haben mit Hinterbliebenen
sprechen können von einem jungen Mann
einem 22-Jährigen Soldat der bei genauso
einem Vorstoß getötet wurde nämlich als
er über den Fluss übergesetzt hat
zusammen mit der sieben anderen
ukrainischen Soldaten da gab es einen
Treffer und alle acht Soldaten wurden
getötet also diese Offensive dort an
dieser Stelle ist mit sehr sehr hohen
Verlusten offenbar verbunden
ja das sind wirklich eindrückliche
Bilder dieses flaggenmeers auf dem
Friedhof der steht ja auch
stellvertretend für diese hohen Verluste
die das Land gerade erleiden muss wie
ist denn dein Eindruck inwiefern sind
denn die Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen da an
der frontaktuell noch bereit diese
Verluste zu tragen
ja es wird immer schwieriger das Bild
bietet sich hier schon ähm man muss ja
sagen dieses flaggenmeer das sieht man
ja leider nicht nur in Odessa sondern
auf fast jedem Friedhof in jedem Ort und
jeder Stadt in der Ukraine und da stehen
Einzelschicksale dahinter ähm getötete
kinderväter Mütter und ähm was uns viele
gesagt haben auch auf diesem Friedhof
ist das was vorher Entsetzen sorgt dass
das ist vor allen Dingen junge Männer
zwischen 20 und 30 die da bei diesem
Fronteinsatz getötet werden das ist da
quasi eine ganze Generation trifft und
das sorgt natürlich für Entsetzen und
dazu kommen natürlich die vielen
Verletzten die vielen traumatisierten
und auch damit muss eine Gesellschaft ja
erst einmal umgehen was die Menschen uns
aber auch sagen wenn wir mit Ihnen über
dieses Thema sprechen ist was ist die
Alternative die Ukraine wurde
angegriffen von den Russen sie
verteidigt sich auf ihrem Territorium
die meisten u China vor allen Dingen die
die russische Besatzung erlebt haben die
wissen auch was das bedeutet nämlich
Mord Vergewaltigung Folter die Ukraine
ist ja dabei diese Fälle zu
dokumentieren und die Menschen sagen uns
wir unterstützen die Streitkräfte nach
wie vor weil sie verteidigen unsere
Freiheit
ja das sind wirklich
erschreckende Einblicke jetzt auch immer
noch eineinhalb Jahre nach Kriegsbeginn
diese wahnsinnig wichtig menschliche
Perspektive auf diesen Angriffskrieg
Anne du bist aktuell in hakiv weiter
östlich das haben wir gerade schon
gehört soll die Stadt kubianz jetzt
evakuiert werden kannst du uns sagen wie
bedrohlich diese Lager aktuell dort ist
naja offenbar so bedrohlich dass die
Ukraine Truppen in die Region verlegt
ihr habt es eben ja schon angesprochen
Truppen die ihnen dann an anderen
Frontabschnitten vermutlich fehlen
werden
kobjandskis ja eine Stadt die gleich zu
Kriegsbeginn von den Russen eingenommen
wurde dann letztes Jahr im September in
dieser großen Gegenoffensive befreit
wurde ich selbst war zweimal in
kopianske einmal im Dezember da war es
in der Stadt eigentlich relativ ruhig
relativ leer auch weil viele Menschen
gar nicht mehr zurückgekehrt sind wir
waren dort in einem vor Ort mit den
Rettungsdiensten der unter der Ukraine
unterwegs sind da unter Beschuss geraten
weil eben dort die Front auch noch sehr
nah war als wäre März dann wieder nach
Kopien sind war die Situation eine
völlig andere das Stadtzentrum lag da
schon unter heftigem Beschuss auch
damals hieß es schon die Menschen wir
sollen werden aufgefordert die Stadt zu
verlassen viele machen das nicht vor
allen Dingen die alten die Kranken die
bleiben die sagen wo sollen wir hin dass
es unsere Heimat wir haben überhaupt
keinen Geld umzugehen aber diesmal ist
es wohl offenbar tatsächlich ernst das
gab heute eine tote Frau bei russischen
Beschuss in kopieranzt die Evakuierungen
laufen vor allen Dingen Kinder sollen
aus der Stadt herausgebracht werden und
in der letzten Woche wurden insgesamt
436 Menschen ausprobieren evakuiert
ja Anne vielen vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzung von vor Ort und alles Gute
für dich in die Ukraine
ja und über diese Stadt über copyansk
spreche ich jetzt auch noch mal mit
militär-experte Gustav gressel und auch
hier wieder der Hinweis wenn ihr Fragen
an ihn habt oder eure Meinung zum Thema
mit uns teilen wird dann tut das gerne
im Youtube Chat oder per Mail hallo Herr
Kresse hallo
wir haben es schon gehört es wird gerade
aus Kiew um cobians werden heftige
Angriffe russischer Truppen gemeldet wie
schätzen sind Sie denn die Lage dort ein
und wie gut sind die Ukrainer dort
militärisch aktuell aufgestellt
wir wissen über diesen Frontabschnitt
weit weniger als über die
Frontabschnitte wo die Gegend Offensive
läuft es gibt diese russischen offensiv
Tätigkeiten schon seit etwa einem Monat
allerdings konnte die Ukraine bis jetzt
die meisten Angriffe abwehren bzw
verlorenes Gelände mit Gegenangriffen
meist wieder zurücknehmen
die Ukraine vermutet da oben eine
kräftekonzentration von etwa 100.000
russischen Soldaten mit
bis zu 900 Kampfpanzern also eine enorm
starke Konzentration an Kräften man muss
aber sagen bisher sind die noch nicht in
dieser Stärke in Erscheinung getreten
das heißt
wir wissen nicht ob diese Angaben
übertrieben sind oder ob tatsächlich die
russischen Streitkräfte in diesem Sektor
so stark sind es lässt sich auch aus
sozialen Medien oder Videoaufnahmen kaum
belegen weil es aus diesem aus diesem
Raum eigentlich kam kaum Aufzeichnungen
oder irgendwelche Foto dokumentarischen
Belege gibt also da ist
unsererseits wirklich Rätselraten
angezeigt aber die Ukraine sind nur
besorgt dass diese Offensive in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen Anschwung
gewinnt und das eben die russische Armee
ich hier weitere Gelände Gewinne machen
können wird die Frage warum die
russische Armee hier angreift wenn sie
im Süden eigentlich verteidigen sollte
ist eine eigentlich berechtigte
wahrscheinlich ist es so dass diese
Offensive direkt von Putin befohlen
wurde der ja nach wie vor am Ziel der
unter Anführungszeichen Befreiung des
gesamten donetzka und luganska Oblast
als Priorität festhält und
Kopien das wäre also der nordzugang
Richtung slavianz klammertors die
letzten großen Städte des Don jetzt die
ukrainische Hand sind
in dem Sinn sozusagen passt das was
jetzt passiert in
das Bild vergangener Putin Wünschen nach
offensivtätigkeit auf diesem Sektor aber
wie gesagt das
dünnt die Russen im Süden aus und verl
agert Kräfte in den Norden die im Süden
fehlen die russische Armee ist
überwiegend der Ansicht dass die dass
man russische Seite eigentlich
verteidigen sollte und die Kräfte nicht
den neuen Angriffs Handlungen
verschwenden soll weil die enorme
Verluste und Kosten bedeuten aber wieso
oft ersetzt sich der Präsident gegenüber
seiner Armeeführung durch
ja und so ganz viel passiert ja jetzt
seit einigen Wochen schon nicht das ist
ein ständiges vor und zurück und
deswegen stellt sich auch immer wieder
die Frage weiterer westlicher
Unterstützung Berlin sendet der aktuell
weitere Militärhilfen die im fassen neue
iristische startgeräte bodenüberwachungs
Radare und Nebelgranaten die Lieferung
von den oft geforderten Taurus Raketen
die wird aber heftig diskutiert und der
ukrainische Außenminister Metro Kollegah
hat dazu das gesagt
wenn unsere Partner von uns eine
Garantie verlangen dass diese oder jene
Waffe nur auf ukrainischem Boden
eingesetzt wird werden wir diese
Garantie geben und sie einhalten es gab
bereits einige Gelegenheiten bei denen
wir solche Versprechen gegeben und auch
eingehalten haben
was würde die Lieferung von Taurus
Raketen an die Ukraine aktuell am
Kriegsverlauf verändern können und
wahrscheinlich relativ wenig aber es
würde der Ukraine die Möglichkeit geben
das was sie jetzt tut schon weiter
vorzusetzen die Ukraine hat zu
Unterstützung ihre Offensive im Süden
wie auch zur Abwehr russische
angriffstätigkeiten im dornbass
wahlflugkörper länger Reichweite also
die britischen
Storm Shadow und die französischen Skype
eingesetzt um wichtige Ziele in der
Tiefe zu treffen ganz bekannt natürlich
Brücken
Verkehrsinfrastruktur die den Russen
schwer möglich machen Munition und
Nachschub heranzubringen
Munitionsdepots zweiter wichtiger
Treffpunkt und auch sehr wichtig
Kommando Bunker also Stellen wo
russische Kommandeure sitzen das
Lagebild verarbeiten Ihre
truppenbefehligen wenn die natürlich zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt
ausgeschaltet werden dann ist das Chaos
und die Verwirrung in
den beiden russischen Kräften relativ
hoch weil
die russische Armee sehr straff ist in
ihrer Führungsstrukturen man auf Befehle
von oben wartet die
benachbarten Regimenter sich nicht
selbst kurzschließen sondern quasi immer
durch das vorgesetzte Kommando
koordiniert werden und da ist dann
ausschalten eines befehlsbunkers er ein
ein wichtiges Mittel russische
offensivtätigkeiten aber auch defensiv
Tätigkeiten zu stören
jetzt ist natürlich das Problem dass
diese Geräte nicht unbedingt billig sind
und dass die Vorräte der Briten und der
Franzosen an diesen Marschflugkörpern
nicht unendlich sind und das natürlich
Großbritannien und Frankreich auch nicht
alle ihre Marcel Körper dienen besitzt
sind jetzt den Ukraine auswendigen
könnten für die verwend im Zuge der
Abwehr jetzt der kopiansoffensive bzw
der Vortrag der gegen Offensive im Süden
Taurus ist in etwa dasselbe wie
die französische Skype oder die
britische Storm Shadow und wenn man
Taurus mit in die Waagschale wirft dann
wäre die
munitionsbeschaffung in dieser
reichweitenklasse für die Ukraine
deutlich einfacher zu bewerkstelligen
und die Briten und die Franzosen werden
dann auch sozusagen durch die deutschen
Flugkörper ergänzt und das munitionspool
wäre größer und die Ukrainer können
diese Tätigkeiten die sie jetzt machen
sicherlich länger und nachhaltiger
vortragen das wäre sozusagen warum
Taurus wichtig ist
eine Taurus genauso wie Storm Shadow ist
auch was seine
gps-abhängigkeit angeht weit besser
geeignet sehr schwer verteidigte und mit
störsen dann ausgestattete Ziele zu
treffen weil er einfach eine
intelligente Kamera und intelligenten
Zugkraft drin ist der das Gelände
vergleichen kann der sozusagen den
Körper auch ohne
Funkverbindungen ohne Satelliten
Navigation ins Ziel lenken kann und
da haben die Ukraine mit dem britischen
marschallkörpern auch schon sehr gute
Erfahrung gemacht dass sie dass sie
schwer verteidigen eine Ziele einfach
leichter ausschalten können mit diesen
Geräten das etwa mit amerikanischen
Heimat die zerstören völlig sind wenn
man wenn man GPS mit Stör sein dann
überlagert
ja mit britischem Gerät hat man also
gute Erfahrungen gemacht jetzt fragen
sich ja einige im Chat wieso ist
Deutschland so zögerlich mit dem Taurus
und der Reichweitenbegrenzung glaubt man
immer noch an eine Eskalation oder will
man es gar hinauszögern wegen der USA
ja das ist die Wiederholung der ganzen
panzerdebatte
man will das System nicht liefern zu
lange die USA kein equalentes System
liefern und das stößt natürlich schon
die europäischen Verbündeten an den Kopf
weil Frankreich ein Großbritannien dann
schon sagen was hast du denn für Angst
vor Eskalation wir liefern dieses
Systeme seit Monaten und es passiert
nicht die russische Armee hat gar nicht
die Kräfte über den Krieg in Ukraine
hinaus irgendeine andere Front
anzureißen und gegen die NATO oder ein
NATO Mitglied
vorzugehen und das
erschüttert schon ein bisschen auch das
Vertrauen in beiden anderen europäischen
all was hier was hier in Berlin passiert
man muss ein zweiter sozusagen der
Taurus hat natürlich auch Gegenmaßnahmen
elektronische Gegenmaßnahmen die
spezifisch gebaut und ausgelegt wurden
um eben russische
fliegerabwehrsysteme zu täuschen und
auszuschalten
weil vor allen Dingen für Schweden aber
auch für Deutschland der Taurus ja im
für die eventuelle Kampfführung und
Verteidigung der NATO im Ostseeraum
enorm wichtig ist um dort etwa die
baltische Flotte anzugreifen und die
Küsten Artillerie Stellungen bzw
raketenstellungen der Russen in diesem
Raum anzugreifen
es kann natürlich sein dass hier
technische Bedenken auf vorliegen dass
man den Taurus mit all diesen
elektronischen Gegenmaßnahmen im vollen
Umfang liest oder ob man nicht das eine
oder andere System aus
Geheimhaltungsgründen ausbauen will
aber wir erfahren ja leider nicht ganz
was der wirkliche Hintergrund dieser
umbaudebatte
des Taurus beinhaltet ob es dabei
wirklich um die Reichweite geht das
wären relativ kindischer Grund
denn die Reichweite an sich sagt ja
wenig aus wo ich das Ziel treffe die
Ukraine schießen die britischen oder
französischen skalpern am Flughafen ja
auch weit hinter der Front ab damit sie
ihre Flugzeuge nicht in den
Gefährdungsbereich russischer Raketen
bringen
und
Kollege hat es ja vorhin im Beitrag auch
schon gesagt die Ukraine hat als wohl
Paris als auch London zugesichert das
ist diese Marvel Körper nicht einsetzen
wird um russisches Territorium
Einrichtungen in Russland selbst zu
treffen und das hat die Ukraine bisher
auch eingehalten und selbst wenn man die
Reichweite von Taurus begrenzen würde es
gibt ja sozusagen es gibt ja Gegenden wo
man Russland mit der Steinschleuder
treffen kann in dem Sinn ist diese diese
Reichweite etwas absurd
und zum Schluss haben wir noch eine
Frage die die Gegenseite betrifft fire
Eagle fragt auf Youtube was passiert
wenn Russland im Norden die nächsten
Wochen durchbricht was will die Ukraine
dann machen weiter im Süden kämpfen
dann müsste sie Kräfte im Süden
herauslösen und in den Norden verlegen
das geht aus ukrainischer Sicht
schon weil man ja an einer inneren Linie
kämpft das heißt die eine
kräfteverlegung sozusagen quer durchs
eigene Land ist also ukrainischer Sicht
immer schneller zu bewerkstelligen als
eine
[Musik]
kräfteverlegung aus russischer Sicht
wenn er so in
Moskau versucht Kräfte
jetzt ausprobieren runter zu verlegen
oder aus dem Raum probieren es
runterzulegen etwa in südsektor da
müssen die Außen rumfahren je nach
verkehrsbegegnungen sogar eventuell über
die kehrbrücke und
dieser Weg dauert weit länger als bei
den Ukrainern die auf der Innenlinie
erinnern Linie fahren natürlich müsste
die Ukraine dann z.B auch
Reserveeinheiten die in Erholung sind
wird das neue Chor
sofort dann in den Raum kopierensk
hineinverlegen
und man muss aber auch dazu sagen dass
die Geographie in diesem nordset da
eigentlich den Verteidiger begünstigt da
gibt es aber Flussläufe die man
überqueren muss
da gibt es ausgedehnte Wald und
aullandschaften
und die Möglichkeit hier das Gelände für
sich zu nutzen um die Russen zu
verzögern und in den Fluss dabei zu
bringen am Vormarsch sind hier aus
ukrainischer Sicht günstig
die Ukraine hat ja auch eine Zeit lang
überlegt ob sie selbst ihre gegen
Offensive ob sie im Süden vorträgt oder
im Norden und aus genau denselben
Gründen die ich jetzt sozusagen als
Heimschule für die russische Offensive
angeführt hat hat man sich dann
letztendlich für den Süden entschieden
vielen Dank für
diese Antworten auf meine Fragen auf die
Fragen der Community und vielleicht bis
bald schönen Abend noch vielen
herzlichen Dank